[Música]
é muito estranho está dando uma palestra
sobre empreendedorismo porque eu sou
muito provavelmente a pessoa que vocês
vão conhecer que menos que esse
empreendedor na vida eu sou empresário
estou muito feliz como empresário mas
quando eu tenho que preencher um
formulário quando tem um campo de
profissão a primeira coisa que eu pensei
em colocar a informática que desde que
me entendo por gente está na frente de
um computador
a segunda coisa que eu penso em colocar
engenheiro porque eu me formei em
engenharia embora nunca tenha construído
em uma calçada
só depois é que eu lembro de colocar
empresário coisa disse a empresária
muito anti eu venho de família essa
coisa de não querer ser empresário meus
pais foram muito provavelmente o casal
mais feliz que eu já conheci e o modelo
de felicidade deles era não têm muitas
ambições
eles acreditavam que quando você tem a
ambição você fica sempre pensando no que
você quer ter e fica triste que ainda
não tem aquilo é eventualmente você até
trabalha demais e trabalhando que você
não gosta pra ganhar dinheiro próprio
técnico que você adiciona a minha mãe
conta uma história que quando eu era bem
pequeno ela participou de uma atividade
de grupo em que várias mães tinham que
fazer uma redação sobre o que queriam
que os filhos fossem quando crescer sem
a maioria das mães redações mais ou
menos óbvios queriam que os filhos os
médicos advogados e outras mães fizeram
redações mais elaboradas
disseram que queriam que os filhos
fossem pessoas comprometidas um mundo
melhor o que fossem pessoas dignas
minha mãe conta que só pegou aquela
folha de papel da redação colocou assim
na horizontal escreveu a palavra felizes
porque não precisava se alguma coisa
específico na vida pra ser feliz basta
fazer o que gostasse daí criado nessa
família com toda essa essa idéia de
simplicidade
pra mim era muito fácil perceber que eu
ia ser feliz com o emprego fazendo uma
coisa que gostasse não precisava ganhar
muito dinheiro e pra mim sem empresário
sempre pareceu inverso desse caminho
para a felicidade e eu achava prass
empresário você precisava ter ambição e
por consequência por precisar ser
ambicioso não ia ser feliz pelo menos eu
não conseguia me
feliz com o meu empresário minha grande
paixão era remetam eu desde criança
gostava muito de música
mas quando o jovem me interessei muito
rendimento eu fiquei completamente
apaixonada o rendimento é obviamente
então o que eu queria fazer da vida ela
tem uma banda de heavy metal queria ser
rock está aí eu não sabia cantar num
cantava bem eu tinha uma tremenda
dificuldade de encarar a platéia encarar
vocês aqui é uma dificuldade tremenda
daí eu resolvi aprender o instrumento
tentei tocar guitarra
não consegui achei muito complicado foi
o instrumento mais simples 78 abaixo
e eu era o baixista absurdamente
medíocre por mais que eu estudasse eu
percebia que qualquer amigo meu quando
compravam baixo até quando pegava o meu
baixo emprestado para treinar há dois
meses estava tocando o melhor do que
tentava há dois anos trocar né
aí foi aquela coisa de montar a banda de
rendimento não ia dar certo
infelizmente eu tinha uma outra paixão
eu era completamente fissurado em
informática desde os 12 anos de idade
estava na frente de um computador era
aquele menininho nerd que não saía da
frente do computador
daí quando eu tive que procurar emprego
foi muito natural para mim procurar
emprego no ramo de informática foi
professor de de informática muito feliz
como professor de informática
depois trabalhei com computadores em
agências de publicidade e foi também
muito feliz trabalhando na agência de
publicidade em 1994 apareceu aqui no
brasil os primórdios do que seria a
internet antes da internet apareceu um
negócio chamado bds eram computadores
que se conectavam e as pessoas deixavam
mensagens deixavam arquivos nessa bbbs e
depois outras pessoas entravam pegava
com as mensagens aqueles arquivos
funcionava muito lento mas é parecido
com a internet
eu como era um cara mais nerd entre os
nerds
eu não era só um usuário dbs eu era que
se chamava na época de 1 sinop
o operador do sistema eu tinha uma bbbs
um desses temas em casa
daí quando a internet chegou no brasil
aquele meu hobby da bbs ficou totalmente
obsoleto não tinha mais razão de ser que
a internet era mais rápido era mais
barato tinha mais gente era mais
eficiente
então aquele revólver acabou de uma hora
pra outra como era o cara que organizava
bbbs
eu resolvi ser uma pessoa que fosse
fazer alguma coisa na internet e não ser
só o usuário
daí eu tiver a oportunidade de juntar as
minhas duas grandes paixões informática
e heavy metal e fez o primeiro site de
rendimento do brasil
whiplash ponto net ela só um hobby mas
ela sobe absurdamente apaixonante
eu percebi que de repente o site teve
sem acesso algum dia eu fiquei empolgado
comecei a trabalhar mais nele no outro
na outra semana teve 500 acesso ea chec
no máximo e comecei a aplicar mais tempo
nele e aí teve mil acessos de repente no
meio putzke coisa legal e foi ficando
cada vez mais apaixonado por aquilo e
aquele robe começou a tomar todo o meu
tempo livre eu trabalhava chegava em
casa ea cuidar desse site
no outro dia eu trabalhava pra casa ea
cuidar desse site todo o meu tempo livre
era para site era o que eu gostava de
fazer
mas era só um hobby a quantidade de
acessos foi crescendo até que no final
de 96 sem esperar muito o site foi
classificado entre os 10 melhores sites
de música do brasil num concurso que
tinha na época chamado the best
os acesso deram uma boa subida nessa
época e junto com o aumento dos acessos
aconteceu novamente uma coisa que não
esperava o site não podia mais ficar
hospedado em um servidor gratuito e a
settra e eu tive que começar a gastar
dinheiro com ele tive que botar um
servidor pago era informe que tomava
todo o meu tempo e começou a tomar todo
o meu tempo e metade do meu salário
não tem nada que não dê pra piorar né
finalzinho da década de 90 teve uma
crise econômica de desvalorização do
real o dólar passou de r$1 para 3 reais
em uma semana
daí aquele robe que consumir metade do
meu salário como o site estava hospedado
nos estados unidos passou a consumir
quase o dobro do meu salário porque não
tinha como manter daquele jeito não dava
pra ser só um hobby eu pensei vou tentar
conseguir um anunciante para manter esse
hobby funcionando então começou um hobby
serra mas vou tentar conseguir
anunciantes a a grande vantagem de ter
sido um começado numa época muito onde
não tinha muitos sites era que eu era o
primeiro site e punam ter concorrente
também o melhor site heavy metal do
brasil né
daí eu tentei procurar anunciantes foi
relativamente fácil de encontrar e
sempre que tem uma banda de heavy metal
do brasil
a melhor opção para anunciar nesse ponto
net não tinha muitos concorrentes quando
uma banda de rap meta daqui do brasil
queria lançar um disco
a melhor opção para anunciar neste ponto
net
daí eu não só conseguir dinheiro para
manter aquele robe funcionando como fui
surpreendido de repente estava dando
mais dinheiro do que o meu salário
será que dá pra viver hobby que parecia
um sonho impossível mas vou tentar
só que era tão viciado com a coisa do
salário eu achava que quando eu não
tivesse um salário no final do mês eu
não ia conseguir dormir na que por
enquanto é que eu vou ganhar no mês que
vem
daí eu não conseguia imaginar empresário
eu pensei assim como eu vou ganhando o
meu salário então tirar uma grana isso
do site está sobrando dinheiro eu vou
guardar dinheiro vai largar o emprego
vai dar errado esse negócio viver de
rendimento não dá certo
e daí eu tenho uma grana guardada pra me
sustentar até conseguir emprego esse
negócio de errado né beleza estabelece
uma meta quando está x mil reais
uma empresa só que o que ocorreu
conseguir juntar aquele dinheiro mas na
hora de pedir demissão eu pensava pô
esse negócio vai dar certo eu vou juntar
um pouquinho mais de dinheiro pra ficar
mais segura passava mais seis meses
estabeleceu uma nova meta
chegava na tela meta
putz o negócio não vai dar certo eu
estabeleci uma nova meta
nesse meio tempo aconteceu uma coisa que
só acontece uma vez na vida da pessoa
eu fui chamado pra ir no show do milhão
do sbt
eu conheci silvio santos
não cabe aqui explicar os motivos mas eu
não ganhei muito dinheiro eu ganhei
muito menos do que as pessoas costumam
ganhar no show do milhão
mas eu ganhei uma grana que era mais do
que suficiente para largar o emprego e
viver daquele meu sonho
aí no outro dia fui falar com o meu
patrão nela o sbt conheceu silvio santos
tudo mas ganhei essa grana e amanhã não
vem mais
eu vou largar o emprego para viver desse
meu sonho esse site aqui qualquer coisa
de errado vocês me aceitem de volta né
só que pra minha surpresa o meu patrão
me ofereceu um aumento de salário na
época ele praticamente dobrou o meu
salário porque eu era um funcionário
bacana eu não queria perder
daí de novo eu digo os planos de negócio
não vai dar certo com esse salário tão
logo agora vou largar vou deixar pra lá
e depois hoje está um pouco mais
dinheiro
dessa forma se passaram acreditem se
quiser dez anos com o site do núcleo
situação econômica favorável no brasil é
de 171 dinheiro guardado e eu não tinha
coragem de largar o site por medo de dar
errado mas em 2008 finalmente consegui
pedir demissão não de uma semana e
estourou a crise de 2008
os anunciantes sumiram o dólar triplicou
de valor de novo tudo né deu errado mas
quando eu tava em casa mesmo com um
pensando pô você quiser ver mesmo com
pouco dinheiro e tal mas eu estava
extremamente feliz de fazer o que eu
queria fazer
eu pensei naquela hora o cara se for pra
viver sem grana para viajar sem grana
pra em show sem grana pra nada
estou tranqüilo porque estou fazendo o
que eu quero de novo aconteceu uma coisa
que não pensava antes eu tinha de
dividir metade do meu tempo o emprego ea
outra metade cuidando do site
quando eu larguei meu emprego para
cuidar só do site
a quantidade de acessos disparou porque
conseguiu botar mais conteúdo na área
certa a gente chegou a us 10 milhões de
page views no mês número assim que eu
considerava totalmente alcançável
os anunciantes começam a aparecer com
mais freqüência mesmo ainda durante a
em 2008 começou a ficar extremamente
fácil manter o site no ar quando a crise
passou então ficou uma maravilha né
só que por mais que a empresa tenha dado
muito certo
vocês lembram que eu tinha dito que
queria levar uma vida simples né
eu resolvi manter essa empresa a empresa
em 5 mas que o site fosse grande virou
um dos 500 maiores sites do brasil
eu queria manter a empresa absolutamente
simples então escolhi por exemplo não
pessoas porque eu não queria ter que
estar discutindo com ninguém não queriam
estresse de discutir eu queria tomar as
minhas decisões erradas sozinho
inclusive eu queria poder consertar
pelas minhas decisões erradas bem rápido
sem ter que discutir com ninguém eu
decidi que a minha empresa não ia ter
sede na sede da minha empresa qualquer
lugar que eu posso viajar
levo meu notebook uma conexão internet
decente na sede da minha empresa está
comigo eu decidi que não ia ter
secretário secretário não ia ter
telefone meu telefone celular é o
telefone da minha empresa eu decidi que
não ia de funcionários têm colaboradores
pagos mas não tem funcionários
um dos meus maiores medos era aqui a
coisa da empresa roubasse a vida simples
eu queria ter e feliz mas paradoxalmente
o que ocorreu é que sem empresário me
permite levar uma vida muito mais
simples do que poderia levar a um
empregado e o que talvez pouca gente
pensa todo todo mundo pensa em si
empresário leva uma vida mais complexa
né
sem precisar me permitiu ser o próprio
patrão eu tive ótimos patrões enquanto
empregados ótimo chefes mas é muito
melhor não ter patrão e não tem chefe
sem empresário me permitiu não ter
horário seu acordo na hora que quero e
dominará que quer aí todo mundo tem essa
coisa tá preta vai acordar vagabundo
deve acordar meio dia todo dia
na verdade o acorda às 6 horas da manhã
todo dia vou dormir tarde eventualmente
o bar à noite mas não é porque eu tenho
um horário fixo é porque eu tenho muita
atenção e fazer o que eu faço todo dia e
gosto de acordar cedo para fazer isso e
domi está nos fazendo isso
ser patrão me permitiu também não tem
mais aquele drama do domingo você pensar
que por amanhã vou ter que trabalhar
fazer um serviço chato não sei que tal
pra mim hoje sexta sábado domingo
segunda sessão todos dias iguais
sem empresário me permitiu inclusive não
tem mais que usar calça comprida e
sapato fechado me perguntaram se eu
podia me dar uma palestra no tedx a
primeira coisa vai ficar apavorada
aterrorizante dar uma palestra no tedx a
segunda coisa fui eu perguntei pra quem
me convidou eu posso dar a palestra de
bermuda chinelo e camiseta porque não
uma coisa que me representa muito
eu acho que todo mundo pensa que quando
uma pessoa chega a ser um empresário de
sucesso dos primeiros desejar comprar um
carro né comprar um carrão comprar um
carro do ano troca por uma pick up town
eu fiquei extremamente feliz como
empresário quando eu percebi que como eu
trabalhava de cada
eu não precisava mais de carro me lavar
a alma da área de transporte público
infelizmente não posso andar mais por
causa de segurança mas com dinheiro que
o povo não tendo que comprar o carro
pagar pneu pagar gasolina pagar ipva
pagar seguro quando é preciso perguntar
que sentou na consciência e terminam
gastando muito pouco quase não saiu de
casa trabalho de casa
meu grande medo de viver sem salário no
fim do mês se mostrou uma grande bobagem
que eu aprendi nesse meio tempo que o
empresário pode tem só que aprender a
viver com a média quando uma época de
vacas gordas quando a sua empresa está
ganhando muito e não pode gastar demais
e quando é uma época de vacas magras não
pode também ficar preocupado perdeu o
sono etc
o importante é viver comédia eu tinha
planejado conforme disse no início que
se fosse necessário eu ia levar uma vida
absolutamente simples com muito pouco
dinheiro fazendo o que gostava
no final das contas não foi necessário
levar uma vida tão espartana eu tive
dinheiro pra poder viajar muito mais do
que viajavam antes porque não tinha nada
que me prendesse da minha cidade
tive dinheiro pra mim muito show e muito
mais shows que eu achei que fosse ver na
minha vida tive dinheiro para casar com
o amor da minha vida
o tipo durante esses 20 anos muitas
propostas e ofertas pra ganhar mais
dinheiro com o site
o dia por exemplo montar uma loja para
vender camisetas de carreira pra pra
esses milhões de usuários
mas o que eu gosto de fazer não é vender
camiseta o que eu gosto de fazer é viver
do meu site fazendo meu site
então abrir mão de ganhar dinheiro com
isso tive proposta de vender o site
cifras que muito provavelmente eu nunca
vou ver de novo poderia ter me
aposentado com a venda e vivido
financeiramente tranquilo mas todas as
vezes que alguém falou em comprar o site
parecia que estava negociando a venda de
um filho sabe como é e desce de manter o
site ficar com ele
houve muitos de meus amigos
principalmente empresários jp ainda vai
se arrepender de não ter ganhado
dinheiro com esse site enquanto podia eu
acho que não me arrependi nesses 20 anos
pelo contrário fui muito feliz e não
tinha muita ambição e eu acho que não
tem ambição é suficiente para continuar
feliz nos próximos 20 anos com o site e
no final das contas nem conseguindo
viver de heavy metal
apesar de não ter conseguido montar
minha banda e apesar de nunca ter
aprendido toca baixo direito
[Aplausos]